ladies and gentlemen we have ourselves a trailer i
was not expecting for enchanted to enchant harder
it's called disenchanted it's going to disney
plus which surprises me because we got word
that the original cast is all going to be here
i'm like why is this not in the theaters then
but john how are you i am wonderful
how are you what in god's name are you possibly
doing embarrassing us both ladies and gentlemen
leave a like the first enchanted is amazing
amazing movie so let's just see what this trailer
i know the change can be scary but it can also
be exciting if i learned anything from meeting
princess on a billboard is that sometimes you
just have to take a leap let's start our new life
okay monroeville
it's all part of the adventure that's
not an adventure that's a landfill
a land filled with adventure
edwards oh it's what they call a fixer-upper
yes once your peasants have dug out the moat
and added a turret and a balcony from which
you can sing i see it now oh okay melvina
monroe i wouldn't buy a rudolph but i
deal in slightly more upscale homes oh
in the andalasia the hardest part of life is
finding your happily ever after this world is very
different if this world is not to your liking then
you must change it i wish what are you gonna do
gonna bring a little andalesia here
he's talking man
i wish for a fairytale life and it's all
gone terribly wrong or terribly right
little both at the last stroke of
12 nothing will be as it was before
whoa we're going dark what have you done
a wicked wicked good she's so good at that i
know i did not think i'd be saying this but
i got a case of the nipple chills oh that was
chilling your heart is warm but you're going to
see a true white shirt for sure yeah
no i don't even need to do a touch test
that looks great it looks lovely like i mean
you know the last one was it was so much more
like exploring new york city and such and this is
much more of an isolated location yeah now but of
course there's still going to be some adventure
to explore as you're seeing you're hopping in
between you know the what is that place like ando
and elasia um and you see that they will probably
hop between them but it's going to be taking
more of like a cinderella riff this time around
stepmother riff yeah it feels like it but yeah i
mean what's what's cool about this because they're
calling it disenchanted is that that first movie
ends you know as you'd expect a happily ever after
type of ending and then it's picking up with
these characters you know however many years later
showing it hasn't exactly been like their their
romance in the family like that the main core of
them has been loving and full of high spirits but
the life there has not been as happily ever after
so then there's such that theme of learning about
the real world and adulthood factoring back into
the gisele character and then uh being a parent
as well and watching how that influence takes hold
in the suburbia lifestyle i i don't know i was
actually like really surprised by how much how
well it actually looked and everyone just slips
back into their role so well despite the fact
that they're like more aware of their age um they
they seem like they're just doing a great like amy
adam just freaking like nailing oh there's always
james bartson just freaking like bam it's awesome
there's something that's that is really exciting
and did it seem like it was just nostalgia heavy
trailer too like it was really moving the story
forward yeah well it hearkened to a lot of you
know disney things as the first enchanted does
it plays on your knowledge of all the tropes
and all the imagery and the iconography but i
thought that this was like a really conscientious
follow-up because yeah like you know you
have that happily ever after big sweeping
ending but what happens when you are living in
a place that isn't quite suited to you and that
is sort of a grueling work a day world and so yeah
this this need to remove yourself and to go out to
the country and to bring a little bit of home you
know to our earth in this case but yeah you know
bring a little bit of your home to this new place
that you're transplanted to like it does look like
a genuine story to tell and then you can have all
the fun on top of that and too i love the blending
of you know you have the cg creep creations and
you have things like that scroll that's talking
to her like those whimsical magical disney things
but you also have some of that 2d splash as well
uh with prince edward at one point which i hope
becomes like a full-on sequence or something
because i think one thing that enchanted is
really great at is not only deconstructing
the disney tropes but also celebrating the
tradition of that kind of you know very grand and
beautiful sort of opulent story uh about
timeless romance and stuff like that but also too
i i imagine there's a lot to say about how
much work it is to maintain that romance even
uh as well as you know just a life that you can
feel at home in and feel you know enchanted by
yeah they're going to get things kinky up and dis
chanted man she's gonna trade her her uh ball gown
in for something latex well you know like that
last one uh if i recall correctly because it's
been a very very very long time since i've seen
enchanted i just remember really being surprised
by how much i enjoyed it uh that that one didn't
seem i don't remember the trailers leaning into
the darkness that the movie could actually do like
there is a fun darkness to be had here especially
with mix because it could have just been amy
adams giselle doing that like funny know what
like she has that line in there about oh what's
something about the home and that was there's a
funny line in um the landfill the atlanta it's a
landfill no it's a land filled with enchantments
yeah yeah yeah yeah i thought like the trailer
would just be a lot more of those jokes but to
see amy adams gizelle get that a chance to do
a darker side of it i think is great and the
addition of maya rudolph i think is excellent yes
you know i wish they didn't reveal i know i wish
it didn't show like oh damn she actually has some
type of uh magical connection to some evil woman
because i i think they they could have alluded or
hinted that better but i would have liked to have
let that just kind of unless the movie clues you
in right away then they haven't spoiled anything
yeah but if they don't then i'm like it's kind
of a bummer that they would show that but again
the production design looks excellent i'm excited
for the musical numbers i'm excited for this cast
to return and overall just this actually looks
like a genuinely great time and i like that it
doesn't feel like remember the last one yeah yeah
it's an actual story and uh if i recall like pip
makes a comment here about how is he actually
talking because that's part of the joke with the
first one yeah when pip comes to the real world
he can't speak yeah uh so something's uh hey the
magic's bleeding over and that'll be fun to see
you know how they justify the change in rules
and things like that and how the magic has
shifted powerful magic man powerful magic if
you're bringing andalesia here i'm hoping that the
new cast especially the family uh gets a chance to
shine though too yeah because it seems like the
daughter is going to be a heavy focus i imagine
they're going to do a lot more themes about
parenting and like because clearly there's aspects
of it that feel like it's playing on like evil
stepmother or cinderella yeah and so i do want
them to to see a little bit more of that like the
difficulties of parenting cinderella thrust into
the position of having to be mom and disciplinary
well you know you have gizelle who is uh
a woman who comes from a disney fairy tale
land and then she has a daughter born in
the real world and so there's got to be a lot of
budding heads yeah over how the they view things
you know wish fulfillment versus reality yeah you
could totally imagine gisele trying to teach her
just things like trying to summon animal friends
to help you via song and that may be perhaps
not working yeah yeah yeah things like that so
i'm looking forward to it but guys what'd you
think about a disenchanted trailer leave your
thoughts down below subscribe click that bell
i think a little mermaid drops so we
gotta we gotta talk about that too